How did the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam peace be upon him
reflects on facing religious differences
in social interaction so that
fluctuation
>> sister slowly in social interaction
>> oh yes
>> differences in religion and
>> okay differences in social interaction
>> social interaction
>> yes
>> so the fluctuating faith Sorry I can't
understand after that fluctuating
>> fluctuating
faith can remain consistent in worship
sister.
How did prophet Muhammad sallallam
reflected difference in religion and
social
>> interaction among the society?
The sister asked the question how did
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam deal with difference in
religion and social interaction where
difference of religion is concerned he
did dawa
my full talks are based on that
he did dawa if a person was a non-Muslim
he tried to convince him about Islam
talked about talked about the other
aspects where it came to social
differences someone is rich or poor he
tried to again preach regarding Islam
If you're rich, you have to give zakat.
So if you analyze, if you read the s of
the prophet, the people loved him.
Whenever any poor man had any difficulty
or rich man also, he used to solve the
difficulty. If people wanted food, he
used to give them food. If people wanted
help, he used to help them. Never did he
let anyone who used to ask for help go
away empty-handed.
Even when the enemies came to him,
he helped them. So he was
when he met the non-Muslims, he did
dawa. When he met the Christians in
maji, the verse of the Quran was
revealed was Allah. So if you know the
Quran, many of the verses of the Quran
are revealed when the prophet was
talking to the non-Muslims.
So what how did the prophet interact?
You read the Quran and you read the
hadith and you get a variety of options.
He helped the Muslims as well as
non-Muslims. So people loved him. Many
of them accepted Islam only because of
the nature of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. The way he spoke,
the way he loved them, the way he was
kind, the way he was merciful, the way
he was gentle. That's what the Quran
says. Had not the prophet been gentle or
if he had been harsh people would have
run away from him. So because of the
nature of the prophet he being kind he
being merciful he being hammed alamin
many of the non-Muslims accepted Islam
and many of the Muslim loved him they
were ready for died they were ready to
die for him that is the reason the
Sahabas
they loved him so much because of his
nature
and he saw to it that he helped the rich
as well as the poor he solved their
problem and that's how people loved him
and they accepted Islam hope that
answers the Question.